ah welcome back to part 8 ah [ __ ] you
there's something swimming in the water
it nearly got to me and holy jeez that
was obnoxious Yap get up get up get up
get up get up get up
it don't
ah I don't like you you don't like me
it's cool I have to get over there oh oh
whoa
okay let's [ __ ] do this run run run
run no ah [ __ ] hate you [ __ ] you
I know what I supposed to go
[ __ ] you
a sound like seriously it's creeping the
hell out I need that
[ __ ] you
what's that bitter something there
whoa that was close I shouldn't have
gone there [ __ ] you whoop that get up
God Jesus jesus [ __ ] christ
get up Daniel get up you [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh no no no no don't screw this
up yeah
Oh
all right good
now forgot to check the timer got that
means there we go
whoop alright good so far
Jesus Christ is sound too much too
[ __ ] much
oh that's great [ __ ] dead end
oh it's a puzzle good
can't have enough of those especially
when there's a [ __ ]
Oh
I got tapped out for some reason
huh so opening McKenna is McKenna's oh
geez
I feel like this is the game we played
when you were little but my life is at
stake when I do it so that's great
as I can go in there instead run run run
run [ __ ] okay I guess I gotta go in here
all right there it is open that
and don't have much oil left
[ __ ] I hate you so much run run run run
that was almost too far there we go
is it even open oh Jesus Christ
don't [ __ ] this up Daniel
all right that's oh I was a [ __ ]
timer
did he make it in God I'm almost out of
oil
I don't want to roam at oh I got one
more thank God Oh oh [ __ ] my [ __ ]
that hurt
okay he does a lot of damage
oh he doesn't like that apparently
uh-huh thank you for
in that
oh this place is great no oh why would
you do that well I'm too far way no no
no no no no no it's too far
[ __ ] that was close
sorry am i me and oh don't go away so
far
come on come on please yeah okay let's
do this nice and easy
Oh mind me just you singing some boxes
come on don't know no oh Jesus Christ I
hate you so much
no offense dude
there we go guessing you gotta go there
no no all right that made it holy [ __ ]
circular motion right no why don't you
work go go
I guess I gotta run through here that's
great
I don't mind that at all
but I have to keep these going I really
don't want to do that because this was
obnoxious oh yeah I really have to all
right
and he doesn't like boxes oh geez
Oh perfect why not
I'm not sure how I'm gonna do this
are we left and I'm out of all great
let's just run in here
I'm out of all kinds a little bit more I
wish I could write something up
everything is so dark and scary and I
don't
that's a I'm a big fan of dark and scary
simple lock what the hell where's that
[ __ ] weed no all right okay so let's
head to the archive tunnels something
large brushed against his leg and he
felt himself being dragged along with
the current of the beasts he pushed
himself about the server help he cried
an ocean swallowed them again
oh Jesus SIL water all right let's keep
going
I assume something's gonna blow out
he's after me
[ __ ] great
okay I got a run run run run run run run
run run run run run run run run
from Daniel Ron Daniel if anything you
should run I'm not scared I'm not scared
what the hell run [ __ ] [ __ ]
lalalalalala nothing going on here
nothing scared of I'm not scared I'm
scared I'm scared I'm scared I'm scared
it's not bad you it's a family it so I'm
kind mean that's not Danny
oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ] I'm not even bought
your brother reading there I got in part
whatever part it is part 8 I think same
part
Jesus welcome back to part 9 that was
scary
that was really really scary and I
shouldn't waste my should know better
look at my oil I got plenty of tinder
boxes but
finally some calm music
The Gambler [ __ ] count Dracula's
[ __ ] castle without
what is this
all right
Oh what the hell
that is definitely an interesting
fountain I must say
so oh I can oh oh that's fun why not
flip flip flip flip there
all right
it's pretty nice Thanks thank god that's
over all right they're gonna take a
break see ya